trappes aura bientôt un nouveau maire
dans ce second tour où c'était une
triangulaire qui était proposé aux
électeurs la liste conduite par ali
avait remporté le scrutin est la gauche
unie pour que tu rappes respire soutenu
par génération europe ecologie les verts
le parti communiste et tout récemment le
parti socialiste totalise 40,4 % des
votes
un grand sentiment de fierté parce que
les trappistes à plus de 40 % ont choisi
de porter la liste de la gauche unie
pour que tu rappes respire est un
également un sentiment de responsabilité
parce que je suis élu dans un contexte
particulier celui de la crise du corona
virus qui frappe encore notre pays et il
y a besoin ici plus qu'ailleurs de
solidarité de services publics
d'engagement de la part des
fonctionnaires de la part des
associations de la ville et nous
disposons ici de grande énergie de
grandes forces vives ma responsabilité
sera de les mobiliser
l'ancien adjoint et membre de la
majorité s'était présenté face à guy
malandain maire sortant en lice pour un
quatrième mandat
soutenu par la république en marche et
lâché entre les deux tours par le parti
socialiste est la tête de liste de pour
trappe la gauche qui agit se classe en
troisième position avec un score de 22
4%
élu en 2001 guy malandain passe donc la
main après dix neuf ans à la tête de la
municipalité et n'a pas décidé encore
s'il siégera dans l'opposition je garde
il garde le souvenir d'avoir fait
d'avoir fait au mieux
rien n'est parfait il ya toujours des
choses à faire
je ne me vois pas passer le bâton du
relais de la course à pied comme ça à
quelqu'un qui que j'ai invité avec son
copain amont là
j'ai invité à venir dans l'équipe pour
terminer par une trahison tout
simplement
distancée de dix points au premier tour
othman nasro lui arrive à la deuxième
place avec 37,18 % des suffrages mais
avec un écart qui s'est resserré cent
soixante et une voie entre sa liste
engage montrable citoyens et celle d'ali
rabais en duo avec mustapha larbaoui
pour le scrutin il envisage de déposer
un recours suite aux résultats de ce
second tour
nous avons fait nous le chemin nous
devions faire pour proposer aux
trappistes une autre alternative que
l'élection de monsieur rabais parce que
je considère que ce serait totalement
catastrophique pour trappe
je le dis j'en parle au conditionnel
puisque on regarde des conditions dans
lesquelles s'est déroulé ce scrutin au
regard des attaques personnelles des
méthodes qui ont été employés nous
envisageons de déposer un recours
à noter que la participation est en
hausse à trappes 38,25 % soit 4 points
en plus par rapport au premier tour
conseils d'installation prévue ce
vendredi 3 juillet à 19 heures en mairie